we're moving forward into linear
functions perpendicular distance is the
name of our doing it's really shot hand
it means perpendicular distance between
appointment line but as you can see it's
a bit of a mouthful so that's why we
just say perpendicular distance because
let's just think about this if you have
two points we're kind of the only real
distance between them is the
perpendicular like what perpendicular to
what and you know what other kind of
this is Divi do you mean like leaning
that distance right um we only mean that
straight-line distance when you've got a
point
our line the reason why we say
perpendicular distance and not just
distance is because or if you have a
line like say this one I've already
drawn over here and you define some
arbitrary point right when you say look
at how far is that point away from that
line the answer is it's as far as you
want it to be because you know I could
say this is the distance or I could say
and this is the distance or this is the
distance I can go any point on that line
and get a distance right so therefore
the only unique way to talk about one
distance the distance is to say I want a
shortest line I want the shortest
distance between that point and that
line and the shortest distance is the
perpendicular distance just like if
you're crossing road the fastest way to
get across is to cross perpendicular to
the direction of the road rather than
kind of go at an angle right so
therefore that's what perpendicular
distance is referring to now I'm going
to do something a bit unusual which is
I'm just going to give you what the
formula is right off the bat okay and
then we're going to prove it after that
I usually like to do it the other way
round because it's kind of like you know
logic where does the formula come from
it comes from the proof but because the
formula is you'll see and some of you
are familiar with it looks quite awkward
I'm just going to give it to you so that
when we prove it you'll be like oh okay
I can see the pieces died before so
here's
modular the absolute value of x 1 plus b
y 1 plus C that's the value all over
square root of a squared plus B squared
so there's a couple of things to know
you have a look at it what are the
pieces that go into this
the first easy piece to identify is on
you've got x1 and y1 which clearly are
talking about this point right so when
there's like some point and some line
the point is x1 y1 right not to be
confused with x and y which are
variables right so this is some actual
values when you look what are the rest
of the pieces don't get overwhelmed by
how much stuff there is yeah
okay good food you're good when you look
at this like that's always got to make
you raise an eyebrow so what's going on
with that clearly Pythagoras is involved
and the reason Pythagoras is involved is
because there are things that are at
right angles okay so we'll get to that
as for the pieces that go into
Pythagoras you've got a B and C what do
you think the a B and C stand for yeah
yeah we've already got the point covered
right we'll walk the line and so that
line is ax plus B Y plus si0 gen4 okay
so that's the a B and C that are these
units in okay so there's the formula and
watch one other little thing to notice
and there's an absolute value there on
the numerator why is that because it's
because it's a distance right so I want
a positive value as opposed to that
other distance for her that you know we
just have two points right the other
distance for me it doesn't have an
absolute value sign on it because
because just the square root like it's
just the square root of this what's this
so by definition its positive right but
as you can see it doesn't take that much
effort to pick out a combination of A's
and B's and C's and X ones and why words
such that you get a negative on the top
and you will I go oh you know I want a
distance so that's where they're going
to end up to get there
your textbook has a proof of this result
there's loads of proof of this result um
it's a good proof it's very hard to
break it's very algebra heavy and a very
conscious to the fact that you've been
doing quite a little bit of algebra
ready right so here's what I'm going to
do instead I'm going to show you a
slightly different proof and you lead a
set of axes so draw one out with me um
just for simplicity's sake let's just do
a basically first quadrant diagram so
that's a lot of good 50
we could use more quadrants but we only
need one to really illustrate what's
going on
you
all right so here's my first quadrant
roughly speaking I said that I'm trying
to avoid a proof super algebra heavy
obviously we're not going to avoid
algebra completely because it is algebra
right uh but what I'm going to try and
do is travel X Y or geometric thinking
muscles okay um this is going to be more
visual heavy and reasoning heavy and
algebra heavy in fact in terms of like
lines of shear lines of working it's
about 1/3 the length of the other proof
okay um but you have to think a bit
harder to see where the pieces come from
and so that's that's a trade-off - in
our first quadrant let's draw a
particular point and a particular Y now
I have to have like it locked into a
particular example so I'm just going to
put a line like that I'll call that my
eggs plus py plus C okay and I'm going
to pick a point and just because I put
spatially V I'm going to pick the point
over here let's call this um let's call
it paper point and it's coordinates are
x1 y1 all right so far so good
so what I'm after is the distance that's
shortest between this point and this
line and you can draw it on right it's
the distance such that you draw an
interval so you get a right angle with
the line it's going to look like this
and there's our right angle okay that's
the actual distance that I'm after so
I'm going to call that distance D
lowercase all right now where are we
going to go from here I need to know a
couple of pieces here I'm going to add
some pieces in here which seem a little
bit arbitrary but you'll see the
direction I'm going in and how try to
use these geometric features to my
advantage okay so from my point P I'm
going to drop a vertical line down from
P down to my actual line that I'm
interested in so it's going to be
vertical parallel to the y-axis so on my
diagram it's going to look something
like this
like that okay so what I have formed is
a triangle and I'm going to do some work
with this triangle song I want to label
I want to have some names here that I
talked about so I'm going to call it
triangle PQR all right
now if this line is vertical right just
for the sake of clarity I'm going to say
that's parallel to this y-axis over here
right okay before I put any more
constructions on this point are over
here actually both Q and R I can work
out their coordinates choose a bit
tricky because of this right angle
business but R is not hard to work out
for instance what's the x coordinate of
ha it's just X 1 because it's vertically
directly underneath P right so that's
easy
the y coordinate it's a little bit
Messier but it's not that hard
let's take our X plus py plus C and
let's put it in a form
that'll make it a little bit easier to
work out what this coordinate is okay so
for instance if I make Y the subject I'm
going to get the y equals minus a plus C
right
so if I make it the subject I've got
this so now what's the y-coordinate of
this point are it's just going to be
minus ax 1 minus C all over me does that
make sense right it's this line right
but it's this particular point or that
line okay so instead of X I have X 1
that's my actual x value so that makes
sense for me so I'm taking my x value
I'm subbing it to the line and that
gives me this corresponding y coordinate
and you with me so far
okay you see what I mean by I try to do
less algebra and I'm trying to do more
geometry and see if you can follow
what's going on
so that gives me this corner ok so far
so good